you don't become good because you think  you're good  has become the greatest of them all you  become  good because you're committed to  becoming better each and every day  i wasn't the biggest player in the nhl  and i didn't have the hardest shot but  what i had was a will to want to score  i got one goal i wanted two i had two i  wanted three it never stopped  through this master class you're going  to learn you have to have a belief in  what you want to accomplish  you don't have to be an athlete to make  an athlete's mindset work for you  unbelievable wayne gretzky the greatest  score ever in the history of the nhl  if you have a love and a passion for  something the rewards are endless  [Applause]  this is masterclass  [Music]  you